and how about the titans it looked like
it was going to be a another 42 to 16
type of a win early on against the
texans and then next thing you know
deshaun watson and company make a game
out of it and it's back and forth and it
was exciting and it was fun and the
texans never quit and the titans never
gave up
and the titans have derrick henry let's
let's hear from derek henry from uh
after the 42 to 36 overtime victory
one thing you need to know about me i'm
looking forward if you in my vision
i'm trying to
run past you
run through you or make you miss
and i'm going to the end zone you know
that's all i'm focused on when i see you
getting grass i'm thinking let's go
you know he typically has been a slow
starter not this year oh man you know
chris chris you know how we always say
oh you pay a running back and things
change nothing's changed with derek
henry he got paid he got rewarded he's
gotten better and yesterday he was
unstoppable and he doesn't need to worry
about running over someone when no one
can catch him you made that point last
night when you see him
accelerate when he's in the open field
and the defensive backs are chasing him
and he builds a lead right that is what
is amazing about a guy that large it's
it's insane it really is it's
unbelievable the fact that yeah he kind
of weaved through traffic you know
slowed down to make a cut to his left
and now
you're thinking all right these dbs are
going to catch him now he's too big he's
not going to be able to start up the
engine and get it going all the way and
there he goes he restarts and pulls away
from everybody i mean it's unbelievable
what we're seeing from him and you're
right traditionally a slow starter man i
mean this guy looks like
he's still a
first or second year running back you
know i think all these years of him
carrying or sharing carries at alabama a
little bit and a little early on his
career here in tennessee it's led to a
whoa fifth year of his career he's still
a spring chicken and looks awesome but i
mean the titans
first off i mean full transparency yeah
pissed off was one of my best bets 21-10
i'm going this game's going just how i
thought it was tennessee titans gonna go
down kick a field goal to go a chip shot
24-10
texans are done they got no chance block
the field goal go score
well what taylor lawan gets hurt strip
sack fumbled j.j watt and all of a
sudden the texans are in the lead and
that jump started them and deshawn
watson started making magic but
mike i don't know the tennessee titans
don't blink that i think they're like
confidence in themselves to overcome or
any big situation
is up there with any team in football
they just don't they're not phased by it
and then it's very impressive and it's
about their head coach he's kind of
instilled that in them
consider these numbers as it relates to
rushing attempts for derrick henry as a
rookie 110
second year 176. third year 215 last
year 303
so far this year
123 which if my math is correct and it
rarely is works out to
393 rushing attempts for the year
i don't know that he can hold up for 393
rushing attempts but he sure looks like
he's holding up and if you can't hit him
and if you hit him and you bounce off of
him you can't hurt him you can't slow
him down this is amazing 588 through
five games let's try that real quick
yeah that is
uh
oh never mind 588 divided by five times
16 is 1881 rushing yards for derrick
henry and if he accelerates later in the
year like we've seen him improve each
year who knows what he's going to do so
the guy's been incredible the titans are
undefeated and they get their biggest
test of the year they scored 42 points
in consecutive games i i don't want to
go on a limb here yeah i don't think
they're going to score 42 against this
deal no maybe they will though no i mean
i i mean well listen there's one thing
people aren't putting together with
tennessee titans and we don't like put
it logically together but does tennessee
titans number two offense in football
sound good because i don't think people
even correlate that they are big plays
in the run game and the pass game 600
yards of offense yesterday i mean that
just tells you they're hitting on all
cylinders watch out for the titans
those bowling ball helmets looking
better and better every day titans 5-0
steelers 5-0 coming up this weekend
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports